c'était ce matin sur la place rouge
quelques courageux allongé au sol pour
former le nombre 2036
c'est l'année des sommes symboliques en
russie jusqu'à laquelle vladimir poutine
pourra gouverner s'il le veut ces jeunes
ont été arrêtés en quelques minutes les
manifestations sont interdites durant le
plébiscitent un vote vraiment hors
normes dont les résultats ont été
publiés avant même la fermeture des
bureaux de scrutin
cette jeune cheminement à l'école les
chausse-trappes chien brèche sans
surprise le oui n'importe où il a
commencé au revoir la démocratie dimitri
blue coat ce qui est auteur journaliste
est un détracteur du président vladimir
poutine
c'est vraiment très triste le pas le bas
rhin
parce que peut-être plus tôt pour pas
par désir de plaire l'accident il
prétendait qu'il observait de certaines
normes des droits de l'homme
démocratique
les observateurs indépendants de
sélection mais là c'est vraiment cette
place la nouvelle constitution permettra
donc à vladimir poutine d facile
tableaux et de solliciter deux autres
mandats il est allé voter lui aussi en
pleine pandémie voté pour préserver le
pays que nous avons construit et que
nous voulons léguer aux prochaines
générations disent at-il la veille en
s'adressant à la nation
la vérité c'est que nos voix n'ont aucun
poids dit karina qui a voté non avec sa
conjointe julia la nouvelle constitution
interdira aussi pour de bon le mariage
des couples gays en retour au moyen-age
ans dit-elle signé
les manifestations semblaient cette fois
tolérer me surveiller les jeux sont
faits un nouveau chapitre s'écrit dans
la grande et complexe histoire de la
russe si thammarat altérer ce coup radio
canada montréal
[Musique]